hey guys welcome to the adrenal body
type webinar so get some paper and a pen
out because you want to take some notes
okay this is going to be an awesome
webinar so let's get started right now
so Who am I dr. Berg most of you know me
for those of you that don't know me I
was in practice for 27 years and in my
Northern Virginia office I was a
director of my office and I also taught
at Howard University as an associate
professor in the area of health and
nutrition okay I also have a
best-selling book it's called the seven
principles of fat burning okay and I
trained over 2,500 doctors over these 27
years I delivered over 4,900 seminars
and also in my youtube videos I have
over 2,000 now and close to almost 52
million views so you could check me out
on youtube I have a lot of information
so that's who I am
really quickly my story okay so I just
want to quickly tell you my story in a
thumbnail sketch I was very very very
unaware of health growing up I could
never just eat a little bit of sugar I
would eat a lot of sugar I don't think
I've ever ate anything green until I was
28 years old except pistachio ice cream
and lime green jello I never ate a
vegetable I always justified it I said I
told people I would eat healthy when I
graduate and when I when I have my own
place
of course that never worked but anyway I
lived in Wisconsin growing up and we
pretty much ate a lot of junk food
all-american diet and my grandmother was
an amazing cook she would bake pies and
cakes and things and I would eat them
the whole thing so in high school I
wrestled I usually did very good in the
beginning of the year I was usually
undefeated towards the end of year I
would burn out because of the energy I
lost because I was eating sugar I would
starve them about a cut weight you know
weigh certain amount and then pig out
right after that and that was really bad
so anyway I did go to state I did
wrestle in college and
very very brittle bones I started
fracturing my bone so I had a lot of
nutritional deficiencies that I was
unaware of back then because it didn't
show up externally it showed up
internally with fatigue with just
fragile bones that was actually vitamin
D vitamin k2 and private amine see
anyway had a lot of dental work probably
every single tooth was filled with
amalgam I had those out never really
helped me because my nutrition just
didn't change I was in the military in
the reserves it was in the Army Reserves
I went into basic training top of my
group and then when I got to Biggs
training I could barely do a push-up
because of my nutrition because my
health was very very weak my recovery
was very very low I barely passed the PT
test okay you couldn't tell on the
outside but the inside was pretty bad so
when I was 28 that's when I hit my
lowest point of my health I had chronic
fatigue syndrome I had severe
constipation I had insomnia there was
nice I didn't even sleep one minute the
whole night that was like torture
because I would lay there and I couldn't
fall asleep I had arthritis and my hands
and my back I had bloodshot eyes I was
searching everywhere we would drive down
the street and my wife and I'd say maybe
they can help me maybe they could help
me I would lead I'd come with a bunch of
vitamins started taking these I had a
warehouse of vitamins and this kept
going on and on and on to the point
where I'm like you know what I got to do
something to make a long story short I
found someone that said you know just
kind of stood back and said okay we're
not going to give you more pills we're
going to find out what's going on and my
dream also completely burned out my
liver was messed up so he started
putting on a program that was very very
strict and I was willing to do anything
at that time
and so I was like some people are not
willing to change I was like hey just
tell me what to do I'll do anything
so I started feeling better and I
started feeling better and then I told
my wife I said that's it I there's
something to this I want to get into
nutrition I want to get into the area of
more in-depth into nutrition and she
says you don't know anything about it
said I'm going to learn so I spent
nights and weekends
studying flying around the country
getting going to postgraduate
certifications I was obsessed about it
for a long time and I still am as well
but anyway I started getting better
better of course now I want to help
other people with the same problems that
I had and I have a lot of reality
because I had pretty much every single
symptom that every single person has
told me in fact all the videos that you
were watching on YouTube those videos
are probably all about me because and
what I did to handle my own body all
right so that's my story so we want to
talk about the adrenal body type because
this relates to not just myself but a
lot of other people but you can see it
starts off you know you start off
looking okay and then you know start
gaining weight in the midsection bigger
bigger and bigger so the adrenal is more
midsection weight skinnier legs
okay the adrenal gland sits on top of
your kidney you got two of them and
they're the gland that adapts your body
to stress so in other words it changes
the physiology of your body to handle
and cope with stress stress so if you
could imagine a tiger chasing you what
would happen to your blood pressure your
blood sugar your muscles every
adaptation that occurs is like the
adrenal adapting your body to that
stress State our bodies were not
designed to live in a sustained stress
environment for that long especially
mental stress and what happens over time
it burns the adrenal glands out so you
have chronic fatigue syndrome so
basically I'll get into the symptoms but
that's really what the adrenal gland
does and I think it's important to know
the function oh by the way the adrenal
gland if you get a blood test on the
adrenal gland rarely will it show a
problem until sometimes 90% of adrenal
has to be unresponsive before it shows
up clinically now you can do a saliva
cortisol test and that's a cool test to
do but you have to do it every four
hours because it goes on a circadian
rhythm okay
so but I'm just going to give you all
the symptoms so you can kind of indicate
it I'm not going to wait for a blood
test to tell me I have an adrenal
problem because if you have majority of
the symptoms then you have it so number
one you're very dispersed thinking all
the time excessively kind of thinking
about this and you switch gears over
here I guess it's multitasking it's hard
to focus basically your attention goes
all over the place sometimes when you go
into a room you'll spot things that are
out of order because the adrenal glands
are all about survival so anything that
is against survival like insanities you
can't tolerate in sanity's too well or
things out of order or things that are
incompetent and competent people slow
people stupid people like you might they
might really rub you the wrong way
too much you also have a hard time
getting up in the morning you don't feel
bright you don't jump out of bed and go
yeah you need coffee you can't get out
of bed sometimes also you're tired
during the day okay
since the adrenal gland is a survival
gland
what you're doing mentally is your serve
out you're trying to survive you never
feel like you're surviving though you
never feel like you're really doing well
you're trying but it's you're never
getting now you're unsatisfied with your
survival and you're you're basically
solving problems 24/7 why because
solving problems is a survival action
so you're basically adrenal glands are
causing you to fixate on problems and
constantly even if there's none there
you'll you'll you'll think they'll find
one right even if you go in a room you
might be the person that spots that
thing that's not quite right you might
have a wonderful day and have that one
little thing that haunts you because
it's a problem that just sticks with you
like like you ignore all the good stuff
but you focus on the bad stuff so that's
what happens and that can keep you from
sleeping also the stress depletes
certain B vitamins as well this is a
someone that's dispersed so you're but a
bit you're it's hard to focus
some talking to you but you're actually
over here you're not really listening
all the time so that's just the adrenal
issue your tolerance for stress is not
as high as it should be so if you can
tolerate a lot of stress you probably
know libido is low this is a little
fence right here low libido eventually
also your blood pressure goes up which
way am I going here okay dispersed I
already talked about that inhaler
because of asthma allergies and asthma
our adrenals think about what they give
you if you have allergies or asthma they
give you steroids Branko steroid
inhalers what's that that's adrenal
hormones so anything that's treated with
adrenal hormones is adrenal problem as
most one allergies one look at acne is
adrenal high androgens blood sugar
issues our adrenal because stress can
trigger to release of insulin yeah
interesting you could become a diabetic
through stress events okay snoring sleep
apnea is adrenal as well leg cramps why
because the a'dreea the adrenals you
lose potassium you lose calcium through
the urine Wow interesting
also brain fog like you're always foggy
or not is clear hair loss alopecia is an
adrenal it's autoimmune
all autoimmune diseases are triggered
are treated with prednisone or cortisone
why is that because they're triggered by
a stress event and their adrenal issues
and because the adrenals control the
white blood cells and they control the
immune system an area that people don't
look at so what we're trying to do is I
want to connect the dots between this
kind of goes beyond the diet and we're
talking about the stress connection to
weight and other problems as well hot
flashes why because the adrenal glands
are the backup gland to the ovaries
during menopause so that's another
interesting thing so we have facial hair
that's androgens sinus
issues have to use the bathroom
frequently especially at night as
adrenal fluid retention cravings for
carbs breads salt okay
carbohydrates breads and salt because
the adrenal gland basically turned your
own food and muscle tissue into sugar
which raises the insulin all these
people are insulin resistance it could
come from the stress event as well not
just the diet so if you're on a
ketogenic diet and you're not losing
weight well let's look at this let's
look at the cortisol connection because
that could be one loose collagen
underneath the arms memory loss you
don't go downstairs like okay what am
what am I going in here for loss of
names why because the adrenal gland
activates cortisol that actually
decreases oxygen in the brain and kills
brain cells upstairs here's the perfect
example of adrenal anything in climb
going up stairs or up a hill you get it
abreast fast your legs get heavy when
you exercise up an incline when you do
flat surface exercise you're fine but
incline is what are you going to know
you're going to run out of oxygen really
fast high altitude not good a lot of
bloating with adrenal because it affects
the digestion think about the flight or
flight mechanism shuts down a part of
the nervous system that affects
digestion and you'll feel bloated after
you eat and your stomach will swell so
let's say you wake over the morning
stomach is a little bit lower and then
at the end of the day you look like
swole out to here that's adrenal could
be inflammation to heartburn GERD acid
reflux all tell the same thing that's
adrenal low tolerance to incompetent
people or low tolerance to stress fly
off the handle easily hard too hard to
just be calm all the time in stressful
environments get tired after you eat
like I mean all these symptoms really
mimic diabetes don't they well that's
because cortisol is really close to
influence far as what what's happening
cortisol will actually increase your
insulin
this is one of my favorite books is
called the cipa collection of medical
illustrations volume 4 the endocrine
system by Frank neder I have probably 10
or 12 of these books because they all
they go I mean I use them so often but
anyway on page 84 this is amazing this
kind of summarizes high levels of
adrenal hormone cortisol action ok look
and look at this you have high
cholesterol low vitamin D levels
excessive brain stimulation look at
glucose increase insulin diabetes
gastric acidity these are all the
symptoms I talked about look at loss of
potassium electrolytes sodium cysts or
inflammation arthritis acne immune
problems I mean there's so many issues
fat that accumulates an essential part
of your body amazing I mean this is the
typical advanced adrenal issue where you
got the belly fat why aren't it going
there because their body is holding fat
around the vital organs as a survival
mechanism it's it eventually grab your
butt muscles and turn them into belly
fat so your butt becomes your belly okay
and then the legs start getting thinner
because your body is going to Rob
proteins from the quadricep so in other
words your Drina 'ls are destructive
they break down protein and your muscles
may turn it to sugar and they convert it
to the belly fat this is all a survival
mechanism so you have muscle wasting
going upstairs out of breath stretch
marks bruising acne Buffalo Hump but
other than that you're perfectly fine
here's the here's what happens
these two this is what looks like you
get two adrenals on top of the kidney
and they're pumping out a lot of
cortisol that's going right into this
gut right there so that's what people
look like they get kind of rosacea or
red cheeks as well okay
so cortisol effects on the joints causes
arthritis dementia because of it will
just causing plaquing of the brain and
decrease oxygen rheumatoid arthritis
it's autoimmune high cholesterol high
blood pressure
ask your paralysis and diabetes I mean
there's a lot of people that have these
conditions but don't they're not really
educated on the adrenal so does not
we'll want to do is I want to talk about
here's the biggest problem the obvious
problem it's this obesity as a disease
that's not true but what happened in the
medical profession has assigned obesity
as the culprit they're not looking
deeper I mean this is like in 2013 the
American Medical Association voted to
classify obesity as a disease in one day
78 million adults 12 million kids were
instantly diagnosed with this disease
now we can put them on treatment they
voted this into existence it wasn't any
type of other like medical evaluation
other than they loaded on it okay well
what I want to do is I want to show you
what to do for the adrenal gland itself
so we can go deeper into what's really
causing this problem here's the problem
the adrenal gland has an outside in it
inside okay as an outside and inside and
the inside is all nerve tissue the
outside is all gland tissue the inside
of the adrenals have what's called the
sympathetic nervous system now you don't
need to know that all you need to know
it's called looks like the flight or
flight mechanism and the flight of fight
is like the on switch so in the body you
have the on switch that actually turns
things on and accelerate things and get
things more stress and then there's an
off switch in the body as well it's
called the parasympathetic so in your
body you have an on and off switch okay
well if you look at the off switch all
these nerves that come to different
organs
the off switch is actually in the top
part of the neck right and the lower
part here and be on switch is all in the
mid-back but if we look at these wires
goes right to the adrenal glands so
there's an on switch for the adrenal
that sympathetic connection to the
adrenal but there's no off switch
there's no parasympathetic control over
the adrenal the inside of the adrenal
what does that mean it means that over
time you can rev up that adrenal but
there's nothing that really brings it
down is not like a neurological off
switch that you can just turn off and
that's why so many people are almost
they get stuck in a stress state and
they can't turn it off so what am I
saying I'm saying that all stress tends
to accumulate now how do I know that
I'll show you why I know that but just
think about it for a second you know you
were kid you had injury you had stress
you ate food things that were stressful
you've been through emotional losses and
stress if you take someone that has a
lot of stress event and their life they
need nearly always have bad adrenals
versus someone that has enough stress in
their life they have really good
adrenals so it's really the accumulation
of stress that really wears out the
adrenals more than anything look at
pregnancy hysterectomy that surgery's
tonsillectomies tonsillectomy infections
severe losses my mother-in-law for
example she pretty much had almost every
organ removed the thyroid ovaries the
gallbladder and then later in life she
started getting surgeries for other
things like a fracture and then going
out under anesthetics which is very
stressful to the body
she has like several of those and I
noticed when she everytime she had that
she kind of lost her cognitive function
and you can see the distress building up
on her body she just didn't recover like
she should have but anyway the point you
need to know is that your body's like a
pin cushion in your you've been
accumulating stress for a long time
so that's really what does it and even
if you take
this takes subjective weight right take
a look at when you started gaining
weight was it after a stress event was
after a pregnancy was it after a loss
take a look at that if it was then we
know you know we need to improve the
adrenals
so again the seminars this webinar is
all about going beyond the food okay
we're just talking about another angle
into why people gain weight so stress
does accumulate okay if you take a look
at injuries and traumas and infections I
mean I I've had okay so now let's get to
a little test that I have in my office
and this is called heart rate
variability what is this saying heart
rate variability it actually is a a tool
to measure something called the
autonomic nervous system so this is an
amazing book on autonomic nerves the
autonomic nervous system is composed of
the nervous system
that's a foundational system that's
behind everything that runs on automatic
okay you have two systems you have
actually three systems but you have the
flooded fight and then you have the it's
called rest and digest
so we got the sympathetic and the person
think so this little gadget measures
both of those states so you can get an
idea of what's happening to a person's
sympathetic nervous system what's
happening to their stress State in a
rest state okay you can you can actually
visualize the recovery state where their
parasympathetic state okay and I've
tested thousands and thousands and
thousands and thousands of people so and
it's quite interesting I can look at
this graph and not even you can you
don't even have to tell me anything
about yourself and I can tell you all
about what's going on inside it's really
cool here's two graphs the small dial
here should always be right up here it
should be very very high okay and the
tall dial should be straight up and down
so it should be like a three o'clock and
I don't have a normal here but anyway
you can see the tall dial is it should
be up and down it's too high and the
bottom dial should be up here and it's
coming down but it's still pretty high
so this person right here is
kind of stuck in stress even when
they're relaxed so typically they would
be thinking more analyzing can't calm
down can't sleep but because they're
sympathetic the parasympathetic this is
a recovery system is quite high they
probably are not going to feel anything
bad they're going to probably cope with
stress find and feel fine it's only when
this thing burns out that you start
feeling it so this person will feel okay
despite having a high level of that
flight or flight mechanism okay but this
one look at this one this person's
activate are the sympathetic sits the
flutter fight is kind of where it's
where it should be but look what the
recovery is it's way down here it should
be way over here so basically they lost
a recovery this person is going to be a
lot worse off they're going to have
they're going to get overwhelmed by
stress easily they're going to not cope
well they're going to have low tolerance
of stress they're not going to sleep too
well because this recovery graph is not
there to get them to bounce back so
they're going to have an adrenal issue
big time
cortisol the hormone for the adrenal
that makes your belly fat is one of the
hormones that makes you fat and it's a
dominating hormone which means even if
you eat good you exercise and you take
your vitamins and do everything if this
hormone is too high it will nullify all
the good things that you're doing okay
so it's not about triggering the fat
burning hormones it's about avoiding the
hormone that blocks these okay so the
most important thing it's a thousand
times more important to avoid stress or
do things to handle stress than it is to
try to stimulate or take something to
try to boost your fat burning hormone so
just make mental note of that now I'm
going to talk about the number one
single most important thing if you have
an adrenal body type it's the fixture
sleep okay drain okay so don't sleep
they can't get to sleep don't fááá sleep
they wake up they don't feel refreshed
at night you go through these four waves
of sleep and you should feel rejuvenated
with adrenal you don't get that so
you're not going to feel rejuvenated
so this is what we need to fix number
one exercise essential but what kind of
exercise walking low intense walking why
because that is lots of oxygen and low
stress
okay so walking is the best exercise for
the adrenal and you need to do it every
single day like 45 minutes to an hour
yoga is the second best thing but
sometimes yoga could be intense to just
do the light type of yoga people stress
this is another big one right probably
fifty percent of people that I see
they're stressed out because of other
people relationships their marriage
their kids parent co-workers oh my gosh
it's crazy so you're going to have to
deal with that but just realize that
that could be the culprit so you really
need to either get new friends get new
family get new co-workers if possible I
don't think that's possible but the
point is that you need to deal with that
and avoid situations as much as you can
but that's a big one so you don't look
like that right there
lots of space is good change of
environment go go invocation get out
there get space don't sit in your room
or watch TV watching Street TV is not a
stress reducing thing because it's
constantly here you're not getting
enough space you're looking at a screen
with pictures okay but this is a very
therapeutic thing in fact I know people
even when they have food allergies
they'll go to another country they get
space they eat like crap and they still
lose weight why is that because of the
space I had a guy a patient who he would
get space like this his belly literally
would shrink and he'd come back and it
just blows up so I know that that's
important because look at with the dream
all you're thinking all the time right
and all the thinking activates the
adrenal so you want to actually get in a
situation where you just stop just
analyzing things so much and that's why
it's important to get out there and walk
and not to turn the computer too often
the sugar has to go we need to bring the
sugars down to zero because the sugar
will deplete nutrients and raise insulin
and block any chance that you're going
to lose weight okay
hidden sugars are fruit yeah fruit
grains including oatmeal can block your
ability to burn fat yogurt has even the
plane has like ten grams of sugar
alcohol will also mess up the liver and
bump your fat burning' for at least 48
hours look at look at an apple an apple
has 19 grams of sugar
unfortunately I used to recommend eating
apples but I'm going to tell you right
now I don't recommend that anymore okay
in my book
that I'm updating you won't see that
anymore we recommend not consuming
apples because the amount of sugar and
also a lot of Margie ml so we want to
avoid fruit especially this sweet apples
now let's see you're not trying to lose
weight well you could probably get away
with it but I'm just telling you there's
a lot of sugar in these apples
unfortunately but I don't want to
deprive you okay because every time I
tell people not to have something that's
what they want it more so there are
things that you can do as substitute
foods so you can eat these food to not
feel like you're deprived I have tons
and tons and tons of alternative foods
you can search dr. Berg keto friendly
eat meals and you'll find these recipes
all over I recommend that you start
making some the next thing you want to
do is increase potassium why potassium
not only is the physiological
tranquilizer and calms the dreams down
but we need about 4700 which would equal
about one two three four five is 10
bananas or five avocados every single
day now instead of doing the bananas and
avocados I recommend doing the salad a
big salad about seven to ten cups not an
all in one sitting
of course I do it but you don't have to
just a couple of big huge salad today
and I highly recommend that you do that
because that will give you a potassium
you cannot fix adrenals without the task
and the calcium is needed to also lower
insulin potassium will
helped restore the adrenal glands and
help you sleep it's very very vital as
far as protein you want three to six
ounces you want three meals a day or two
meals a day okay but make sure that
their protein and fat and you add the
vegetable to that as well you don't have
to consume what I consume if you're a
vegan you don't have to consume this
this has happens to be what I consume I
four eggs a bunch of bacon nitrate free
organic without sugar paleo and I do a
lot of times an avocado and I'll
probably put some cheese in it that's
what I do but I'll probably consume this
I'll do this like pie 11 o'clock in the
morning and then I won't eat until maybe
4:30 sometimes I'll I'll do three meals
maybe I'll do a late dinner small one
but sometimes I'll do two males but I'm
not having snacks because the
intermittent fasting not eating between
meals is really powerful because that
will trigger hormones that will block
your ability to lose weight so in a
minute fasting is basically not snacking
another thing I used to tell people to
do is snack bad advice so I don't
recommend it two to three meals a day no
snacking so how do you do that you want
to add more fat at the meal so you can
go longer without eating what is that
going to do well fats neutral it won't
trigger the insulin factor okay it
allows you to go longer intermittent
fasting will help the adrenal glands why
because every time that you fast it
takes the stress off the digestive
system and it gets you to burn fat which
is a better fuel system it's more
efficient and sugar if you actually rate
sugar in your blood Sugar's go up and
down guess what that does to cortisol
and adrenaline it jacks it up so we want
to do in a minute fasting okay
alpha soda vinegar vital to help with
your visceral fat in your gut it
actually helps break down fat and it's
really really really good for keeping
the pH correctly balanced so your body
can maximize weight loss and it also
have blood sugars and cortisol all right
so now that you know about the adrenals
what do we do about it okay
how do we fix it plan a right here you
need to go into a desert island or some
island and just for the next six months
and rejuvenate okay that's plan a so I'm
good right and you'll come back you lose
tons away if you can't do this right now
okay there's a plan B and that is the
Drina body type kit this is the most
popular comprehensive kit and I want to
explain what it does okay
this kit is composed of the sleep aid
okay sleep aid used to be the adrenal
night formula what I did is they
upgraded it and I added lv9
and trip to man tryptophan to actually
enhance the formula I had this last
night I'll take one before bed had a
beautiful sleep I'm sleeping longer with
it and I wake up feeling refreshed no
grogginess there's no hormones there's
not anything in here that's going to
activate the wrong hormones there's not
melatonin for example it basically
supports your adrenal gland and helps
you get into it rejuvenating its sleep
and I take this one before bed and it's
awesome okay number two cortisol
adrenaline cortisol relief this product
used to be my adrenal day formula I
added an ingredient called a Shogun de
added more of at 200 milligrams and that
also helps lower cortisol even more so
it's mainly for high cortisol when you
take this you take it during the day and
you just feel stress-free you're going
to feel like calm it's going to take
that tension out so the combination of
both of these take this at night this
turn the day one with meal you're going
to feel really really good okay you
don't really have to take this with
meals you can just spread it up through
the day you can take maybe one in the
morning to at night or it doesn't really
even matter you can take them all
together but this right here has
nutrients to support the adrenal gland
itself and rejuvenate the Drina function
the gall bladder why are we recommending
a gall bladder what does that have it to
do with anything well this has a lot of
different gradients and many people have
a
justa problem they have basically your
your stomach is fat because they get a
lot of bloating right so this reduces
bloating for from digestion because it
has bile salts and it has enzymes and
helps things for the stomach it's very
comprehensive but it also has purified
bile salts that help dissolve visceral
fat on the gut so this is more of a fat
dissolving thing okay and then we have
the trace mineral what is the trace
minerals trace minerals are basically
plant-based minerals plant-based
minerals are 15,000 times smaller than
regular minerals the plant-based
minerals are good for building proteins
collagen hair nail skin so when you lose
weight the last thing you want to do is
end up with loose skin this makes the
skin tight it makes this college and
look good it makes your skin look great
it's good for nails it's good for hair
so this is really good for your protein
so that way when you lose weight you
look good so you you don't look bad this
kit also comes with a really cool body
type program online program that give
you a lot more information on many
different topics related to the adrenal
and then also the digital version of the
book okay this gives you a lot of
background data on the adrenals and the
other body types
now there's also two very cool bonuses
that it comes with one is a meal crater
which you know you're going to wonder
what am I going to eat right well you'll
have access to a very cool program for
the rest of your life included to
basically within 30 seconds pick the
meals that you want press a button and
generate an entire week of foods okay
and you can set it for three meals a day
or two meals a day and boom you have the
whole thing now you can actually not
focus on what you're going to eat
tonight you already have the plan for
the whole week it's awesome okay so that
will help you and then the second bonus
is this cool booklet okay this booklet
is how to burn fat and fix your
metabolism this is a summary of my new
book that's coming out that I don't have
out yet but it's coming out that you can
get through in about 20 minutes it's
just the key things you need to know and
it's a quick read and you just follow
this and you can jump in and get started
this lot of people just love this
booklet and you can buy it or you can
just get it as part of it
but it allows you to get the nitty
gritty and what to do and also how to
address the insulin connection as well
so I'm going to throw that in there as
well and so that's the kit now right now
I'm doing a special you can get 10% off
the entire kit so I put a link on this
page or down below depending on what
you're looking at okay so here's the kit
right here this includes everything I
can't promise you that the 10% off will
be activated when you're watching this
because it's for a period of time so you
just want to check to see if the link is
still working it's not working just you
know get it for regular price but here's
the point
a couple questions people want to know
how long does this laughs if you're
taking the usual amount which is one of
these before bed this will last three
months if you're taking one with a meal
this should last about one month
sometimes this is two meals the last two
months or one and a half months and then
this will last depending on how many you
take sometimes is just one you're taking
sometimes and three will last between
one and three months and this lasts
between 1 and 3 months depending on how
much you take but usually saying these
two products are really not long-term
products you may like to take this on a
period of time or over a period of time
and you may want to take this if your
life is very stressful but it lasts
three months so this program will last
anywhere between one and three months
okay but the knowledge that you're going
to learn from the book and the summary
charts and videos are priceless so if
you want to get the kit click down below
and please send me your success story
thanks so much for watching